XML was designed with a number of goals in
mind. One of the most important for purposes of this
class is, it was designed to provide data transfer
that's platform independent. What does that mean? Well the idea
here is that you can have a Producer App.
That's written in any programming language on any operating system
and any type of hardware. And the consumer app
implemented in any other programming language operating system or hardware.
There is no binding between how the consumer app
or the Producer app is implemented, because they both agree
to speak XML to one another. And of course
in addition to consuming XML from the Producer app, the
consumer, wouId also write XML to the Producer app.
Another important goal for XML is that it would be
easy to write programs to read and write XML. The
designers also wanted a data format that could be validated.
So in XML, we write a specification for a
particular type of document. And then any specific examples
of that document that are produced can be validated
against that specification. So BioMed Central has a specification for
the research article format, and any articles that are
produced are validated against that format to ensure They
adhere to the rules for that data model. XML
is designed to be human readable, and as we saw
in the example, we can get a pretty good idea
of what information is contained with in an XML encoding
just by looking at it. And finally, XML is designed
to support a wide variety of applications. We've seen one
application of XML, we're going to take a look at
several others. That essentially span a number of different ways
in which XML can be applied to exchanging data between
applications. If you're interested in more information about this data format,
I encourage you to take a look at the
W3C site. We're going to talk a little bit about what
having a standard means. One of the most important benefits
of there being an XML standard, is that we have
robust parsers in most programming languages, Python included. What this
means for us as data scientists, is that we get
to focus on our own applications. We don't have to
worry about writing parsers. For some ad hoc data format.
Previously each messaging system had its own format
and all were different which made the type
of messaging that we do now very messy,
complex and expensive to do. If everyone uses the
same syntax, it makes writing these systems a
lot faster. And much more reliable. Another advantage for
XML is that it's free. Now, that's free
as in beer but also free from legal encumbrances.
It's not a format that any company owns and may change out from under us. XML
information can be manipulated programmatically. So we can
build databases to support specific types of queries. Or,
we can piece together data from different sources
or take it apart to be reused in
different ways. XML documents can also be reliably
converted into other formats with no loss of information.
XML let's you separate form, or appearance,
from content. So, your XML file contains
your document information, all of your text
and data and identifies it's structure. Formatting
and other processing needs are identified separately
in a Stylesheet or processing system. In
the BoiMed Central example, it is actually the XML that is transformed into HTML
for rendering on the website or into PDF for download. Using a Stylesheet.
And style sheet processing system. The two are combined in output time to
apply the required formatting to the text of data identified by its structure.
This structure might define location, position, order
or any other aspects of the data.